good morning everyone it is awesome
awesome to be here on Monday morning I
always like to start with an exercise so
if you can if you do not have any
mobility impairments if you could please
stand up I know it's Monday morning
sorry all right if you could raise your
hands you have the right idea if you
could raise both of your hands in the
air I'm sorry if you're holding a cup of
coffee or a laptop okay I think I think
there's some people I think you can
raise your hands just a little bit
higher I really get that stretching
because we're at the beginning of the
conference some of you may have been
stuck this morning on the subway alright
so for those of you who can see the
slide don't look at it but on three
we're all gonna raise our hands just a
little bit more okay ready one two three
stretch all right
you can also sit down the point of this
exercise is you can always reach a
little bit higher I had nice slides for
this so cool Coco I also have that
activity because sometimes it takes a v
to gets up for a little bit good morning
everyone the the title of my talk today
is a few good public servants how great
analysis inspires action and I'm really
really excited you guys I took a look at
the agenda for the conference up coming
and it looks like a really really
jam-packed panel lineup you all have for
the next couple days and so there's a
few things that I would like to talk
through uh-oh do we lose the yeah
it's fine I can do it off memory let's
go
cool alright so you can always reach a
little bit higher moving forward um so
I'm actually here to tell you all a few
stories there are a handful of different
stories I want to talk about you have
here just a map of the United States and
because I think for a lot of us who work
in data and analytics a lot of our work
is actually about storytelling so I'm
going to tell you all a few stories from
my time working in DC at the Obama White
House for the last decade or so helping
to stand up Boston's data team and an
analytics team and then I'm going to
talk about how I traveled a bit
throughout the country
and how I landed in New York City even
though I am actually a native of the
state of Massachusetts the great state
of Massachusetts and so the the story
goes I had spent quite a while in DC and
a lot of things have changed since 2016
I actually gave a PI data keynote in
October 2016 I think a couple weeks
right before the election happened and
although I think if anybody turns on the
news you may know that a lot of things
have changed I'm going to talk about
today a few things that have remained
the same regardless of where you are in
our country and I think a huge part of
that has to do with continued civic
engagement which i think is particularly
true here in New York City this is
actually my first time living here over
the last year and I've really seen how
active you all are and I think what is
truly remarkable as I think within the
Civic tech and data community just how
active folks are in policy spaces this
is definitely not true I will not name
other cities but there are a lot of
other cities out there where the turnout
is not the spectacular on a Monday
morning and here in New York City you
know I definitely within the mayor's
office of data analytics at City Hall
the work that we do builds upon a
foundation of incredible work that has
happened you have here a photo of quite
a few students at the very first
hackathon held inside of City Hall
here in New York City it should be no
surprise that as part of this hackathon
was this hack League hosted by beta NYC
and cs4 all within D OE here the kids
built quite a few things that I actually
wanted to scale throughout the cities so
there's a lot of incredible talent here
happening within New York but I'm
actually going to start today's
conference session talking about
sidewalks I have a very very good friend
of mine who describes public policy as
thinking of a sidewalk and thinking of a
sidewalk curb I think what is really
interesting for a lot of you is when you
think about public policy first a lot of
people really struggle to define what is
public policy I think even people who
may have MPP and PA degrees really
struggle with that and she always talks
about the fact that a sidewalk curb ramp
is public policy actually in action and
I know people don't think about this but
if you think about millions and millions
of New Yorkers who walk down the
sidewalk if the fact that the sidewalk
does not just end when you reach the
street the fact that it slopes down and
the fact that individuals with mobility
impairments parents with kids and
strollers can not just fall off where
the sidewalk ends that's actually public
policy in action and I think for a lot
of you who work in data and analytics I
certainly spend a lot of my day-to-day
time trying to figure out how do I
demonstrate what we do on a day to day
basis within the data team so what is
what
this analog what is the image of
analytics in action and I have a fetus
at you so the the closest image I
currently have is this it is on the left
hand side I just took a local law that
actually names the mayor's office of
data analytics we'll talk about it and a
little bit we got actually written into
the city charter late last year and on
the right hand side we got some code up
and what was really interesting is we
had a new data scientist join our team
two weeks ago and Adrienne smoker who is
the deputy chief analytics officer said
she walked over to our data scientists
screen and she literally had a local law
up on one side and code up on the other
side and I said well that's a pretty
good visual of thinking about how
analytics works within government in
particular in in local government it is
thinking about the intersections of
these pieces the piece that's actually
missing in that image that you all saw
is very clear that this person is coding
it's late at night and the reading is
this component that I sometimes think a
lot of analysts forget and a lot of
techies forget which is you have to talk
to people this is actually a framework
within the civic service design lab
which is hosted by NYC opportunity a
sister agency to us at the mayor's
office of data analytics and Mari who
heads up that team we were sitting down
I think a week ago and she said a thing
that we always do and we have to do in
government is talk to people I know it
sounds so incredibly simple but it's
something that people often forget to do
and I think I'm particularly in
government and I won't speak to other
industries that are represented here in
the room today but in particular to
government to local government it is
actually a part of our jobs to
constantly talk to people because we
deliver services for them because we
engage with them every day
and because ultimately we're accountable
to those that we speak to I've been up I
actually cut the sound it's in my office
I've been obsessed about this tweet that
Nate Silver tweeted I'll read it out
loud so everybody can can see it if you
want to be a good data scientist you
should spend 49 percent of your time
developing your statistical intuition
how to ask good questions of the data
another forty nine percent of your time
on domain knowledge improving overall
understanding of your field and only two
percent on methods per se and this to me
was a little bit of an aha moment
because a lot of those percentages can
only be accounted for by actually
talking to people and so I think this is
particularly true in government where
there's been a huge push to be more
data-driven to do a lot of data for good
initiatives and I think it's becoming
increasingly important for all of us to
work on responsible analytics and we can
only do that when we engage with
stakeholders and and with individuals um
I want to pause for a moment these are
not images from the city of New York
these are two images that I've just kept
in my photo Bank because for anyone who
really really likes complex problems
welcome to government so these are two
photos from server rooms that I've
collected over time not the city of New
York here you have some wires next to
some water next to a plugged in toaster
oven on the right hand side you have
wires that I swear were really organized
like two days before that photo and then
we opened up the closet again and then
it looked like that two days later and I
show you all these photos not just so
you can have a chuckle on Monday morning
but because a lot of the work that we do
is really really messy and I don't just
mean on the data front you all are used
to dealing with a lot of data and trying
to figure out how to make sense of all
of that information for us with the
government it's also everything else
it's the policies it's the programs it's
the agencies the people who are
underlying them and I think for anyone
who really really enjoys a challenge
this is constantly top of mind is if you
look at that and you're like I want to
fix that I want to clean that up I want
to help people have cleaner closets
server closets it's a lot of the work
that we do and I think that it's really
really easy oftentimes when you all see
what governments what agencies even the
rest of this presentation that I'm about
to give and think wow it's so clean and
easy and da da da and I'm like it's
actually really messy it takes a lot of
effort a lot of work with by a lot of
teams in order to make sense of a lot of
what we're working on and so rewinding
to 2015 I was feeling pretty good about
myself I was at the city of Boston we
had done what I kind of shared with you
all we were talking to people we were
making sure that we talked to a lot of
city agencies and better understood
what's happening and we were we were
doing some good work there the data team
we actually worked with the fire
department there and we build out the
building intelligence systems tool and
we integrated a ton of information and
we piloted a tool where firefighters and
fire dispatch could actually on demand
be able to figure out what kind of
hazards were located where within
particular buildings this is of course
incredibly important to any public
safety response for any city and what
was really neat about this was that it
was actually one of the firefighters
ideas there in Boston he had just like
if you may go to Europe and you're like
I'm going to this particular city and
I'm gonna drop a bunch of pins down of
all the cafes and restaurants that I
would like to go he had actually created
a Google map where he just dropped a
bunch of pins of buildings that had
hazards in them and we said actually we
can take that we can
we can help you actually build a tool
for that and so we feel pretty good you
know built a couple of things this is an
image of the mayor's dashboard this is
Dan Coe his former chief of staff in
Boston for mayor Walsh and we felt
pretty good we actually delivered
rotating dashboards in the city I will
never live this down and I never want
this title again but I was known as the
dashboard Queen which I never title now
I've told you all and and what was
really interesting is another big
component of great analytics of great
analysis is you want your information
your data to be visual and to be
actionable and so for us that meant how
do we get in front of the executives and
the leaders and what is something that
they actually look at every single day
well just what happens a wall across
from the mayor's desk within his office
and this was something that the mayor's
still to this day uses think about a lot
of the dashboard requests for anybody
who works in probably finance or really
any industry your executives or
leadership is looking for dashboard they
are looking for what our insights so the
mayor would look at the information I
was presented to him and be able to call
Chiefs to be able to call departments
and actually ask some questions why have
your numbers gone up over the last
season over the last week what are some
things that we could do to fund better
programs and so for us this is really a
starting point and so I again feeling
pretty good about myself build some
shiny things within the city of Boston
and got a call one day from the White
House and I had worked within the Obama
White House within the Domestic Policy
Council in 2012-2013 and had gotten a
call in April of 2016 and they said
would you be interested in coming
back and I said you only have a couple
months left so I'm not exactly sure what
you're going to be doing in the last
couple of months of the administration
and then they said well you should talk
to DJ Patil about it and I said okay and
no one can tell DJ this in case you know
him but DJ who is the very first US
chief data scientist and who many folks
say co-founded Co coined the term data
scientist for anyone here who has the
actual title I hopped up the phone with
DJ and then ended up flying down to DC
and he said you know what's really
interesting is that we're trying to make
sustainable a lot of the work that we're
doing within the administration and one
of the ways to do that
is how do we infuse the practices within
state and local governments because
there's all this incredible work that's
been done at the federal level but what
does it actually matter if we're not
touching people's lives on the ground
and so I as I usually do is like DJ what
am I going to be working on Who am I
gonna be working with and you said you
should come up with your own operating
thesis I said I am sold
I will come to DC on that premise I will
fly down over a weekend and come work
for a couple months and it just so
happens that I arrived and I really
really thought that I would be working
on sensor technology drones IOT really
anything buzzword e at the national
level working in partnership with state
and local governments it actually
happened that there were a series of
incredibly terrible shootings July 2016
and it had stirred up a federal
conversation across states and counties
and cities about what were we doing
around criminal justice reform and the
criminal justice system and it just so
happened that I was on the data and
Technology team working with DJ working
with Meghan Smith the u.s. chief
technology officer
I ended up working on the criminal
justice system and I didn't expect that
at all and I won't go too far into the
weeds here to share with you all but the
very first thing I did because I knew
nothing about the system was to talk to
people and that's when I said a couple
slides ago this is something that
President Obama has done again and again
and that I think many many great leaders
doesn't matter if it's in the public or
private sector do they talk to people
and so as with that that I really
started to understand that in these last
six or seven months as a part of this
work I would be faced with a much bigger
challenge that wasn't just about
building shiny tools or dashboards or
visualizations it was how do we tell the
story using data and technology to make
national and federal change and this was
one slide that I probably have put a
couple thousand miles down traveling
around the country with this one
sentence every year 11 million people
cycle through 3,100 local jails costing
20 billion dollars the three largest
mental health facilities throughout the
country are the country's three largest
jails which I will not name here and in
those local jails 64 percent have a
mental illness 68 percent have a
substance use disorder and 44 percent
have chronic health problems and for us
when we talk about the criminal justice
system we look at what the Perino
analysis is of what all the people who
are in those systems and whether or not
they're getting the help that they need
and for me as simple as these two slides
are another big note about great
analysis inspiring action is to filter
your message and to get it to a point
where you can be crisp about exactly
what you are talking about what the
problems and issue areas are
and to actually grab people with what
you're talking about
and so I'll take you all back in time I
have since visited I think at least five
if not more jails throughout the country
county jails throughout the country and
my very first experience was at Cook
County Jail the largest single-site
facility larger than I think 90 plus
acres and we had gone there was the very
first facility that I had visited um and
I'll never forget that moment when we
were exiting the facility and we ended
up stuck in traffic and I had never been
anywhere
never mind picture to jail that you
could be stuck in traffic on the way out
because there were so many individuals
and workers who were there and it took
us 45 minutes to actually get outside of
the jail facility and to me it was more
of this understanding in context of just
the universe that we were in within a
policy issue area so if you think back
to that Sidewalk image this is this is
another image for all of you to take
away with the other thing that I'll say
just as a note I think for anyone who's
like oh none of my data is in exactly
the way that I wanted I can't do the
analysis and it take me 99 percent of my
time to actually get my data shaped the
right way one of the jails that we
visited was really really proud they
slid a one-pager over to us and they
said we've never been able to accurately
count how many people we have in the
jail until recently
here's a one-pager of the counts
male-female etc and for me this was
truly an understanding of I think a lot
of talent that is across the entire
country that is here in the room there's
some really incredible work that can be
done I think in public policy just at
the descriptive analytics side for a lot
of these jurisdictions for a lot of
these programs and for a lot of these
these public policy issue areas
and so of course you're like alright
Kelly I've seen enough images like show
me some numbers and data what was really
interesting about the data-driven
justice initiative which was this
nationwide coalition of a lot of
different communities who had joined and
signed on was that we did not try to
recreate the wheel and I highly
encourage all of you to remember that do
not try to recreate the wheel if you can
figure out who is working on a similar
challenge go talk to them and for us
this was identifying that the University
of Chicago
this was raid ghani's former group there
for those of you who are familiar a
group of students actually took a look
at the data Johnson County Kansas and
based off integrating a few of these
different data sets they were able to
really look and say this is a really
compelling case on the right hand side
this finding a key predictor for someone
on the list was being disconnected from
mental health services around two years
since the last contact and for us when
we walked around the country that all of
those numbers people said that cannot be
right it cannot possibly cost the county
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
per person on on the low end of sending
them to jail and the more communities
that we went to there were some
communities that had a handful of high
frequent utilizers who are cycling in
and out of jail and they found that they
had numbers upwards in the millions
that's how much their various systems
were trying to respond to individuals
who had mental health issues and and
needs and so for me again when it comes
to great analysis try to figure out how
can you tell that story
how can you encapsulate in such a way
that that you're really going to help
move move people along I'm going to try
to speed this up because I know I only
have a couple more minutes with you all
but I want to Segway and start tuck this
as a photo of New York City Hall in case
you've never visited I want to talk
about what that all means I've just told
you all
stories all right Kelly you've traveled
a little bit you've gone to different
communities I got a call one day to come
interview for the chief analytics
officer position here we are I'm gonna
claim this but the best the flagship
data team throughout the country
and the mayor's office of data analytics
has been around in some form or another
for a decade and I think that that is a
testament in and of itself in the great
work that the prior staff and leaders on
the team have done and for me it was
incredibly humbling to come here because
when I was in Boston when I was working
at the White House and even before then
this this is the team to beat right this
this is the team that's working at the
forefront and to be able to say how do
we actually chart out a vision and a
path was really really interesting to me
this is an image of the New York City
org chart for anyone who thinks that
they have a confusing or chart at their
organization this is ours you can find
it online and for us this was really
exciting we're here we got ran into the
org chart office of data analytics and I
always tell this story because for me it
is incredibly important that we think
about how to sustain and to build data
infrastructure into our organizations
and I think for anyone who's paying
attention to local governments different
cities across the country people are
trying to figure out where do I put my
data team should I put it under IT
should I make it an office that reports
in to the executive office should it be
hitched under the various agencies or
programs like do I need a data team for
my marketing team do I need a data team
for my sales team and for us we're
really really lucky that we got written
into the org chart and that has a lot to
do with a lot of our our team members
and people over time being really really
crystal clear on
on what we're doing I we are here we are
a tiny dot for I'm gonna assume that
most of you know that this is a pale
blue dot Carl sake and look it up if in
case you don't know but for us within
the broader cosmos of New York City
it feels some days like where this dot
and I think for a lot of you not gonna
project here it might feel like you're
like this within your broader
organizations or that like one small
team that's working on data and
analytics and you're constantly trying
to explain what am i doing what is my
team doing what are these projects that
we're working on and I think it's really
really important to acknowledge just how
nimble you have to be our team is only a
team of ten and within the broader
ecosystem there are three hundred and
twenty-five thousand government
employees here in New York City it's the
third fourth largest workforce
government workforce throughout the
United States and we have over 125
agencies eight point six million New
Yorkers upon latest count and the budget
of the city is over ninety billion
dollars so some days it feels like
that's us this this tiny little tiny
little dot so I'm actually going to get
a little concrete here with all of you
now which is I've spent a lot of time in
government and private sector and I'm
not going to go into exactly what is
data science what do I think data
science is what do I think data science
in government is but I will put up this
slide which I've spent I think a year in
change working with the team on of what
is data analytics because it's not just
math and I think for a lot of people who
work within broader organizations but
certainly within governments there's
this question of like what are you
working on and what are the ways that
you can frame out what you're working on
and so for us is pretty straightforward
I think you can argue about the
semantics of all of these descriptive
analytics what is happening or has
happened diagnostic analytics
happening predictive analytics what will
happen in the future prescriptive
analytics what should be done about it
and I think what's incredibly
interesting for anyone who understands
public policy if you remember at the
very beginning is that your work can
only start on the left hand side your
work has to start at the left hand side
you have to understand everything that's
up here before you can actually move to
the right hand side there's no universe
where you could start with prescriptive
analytics without understanding what's
happening without understanding the
underlying data sorry I just had to get
on that soapbox for mind and in terms of
what do we actually do I wanted to share
this because this may be helpful
depending on which industry that you're
actually in so the mayor's office of
data analytics within New York City we
do I think we do many things but broadly
chunked into these four advisory
analytics so in this case it's the phone
call that's hey we're doing something
can I get your advice for an hour can I
get on the phone with you or somebody
team so this is actually supporting
agencies on the methodology that they're
working on strategies or even with top
of mind within industry so we get a lot
of those calls and we take them the
second is mechanical analytics projects
so this is I think what a lot of the
conference sessions will entail are
people who are working on very clear
this is my analytics question this is
the data set that we have and this is
we're actually trying to push forward on
this is our hypothesis that we're trying
to test we do those in partnership with
city agencies they're really really
interesting items to me which are
slightly different I think for us is
that we have an analytic SWAT team and
that means and we does not a separate
team within the team but that means that
we could deploy if there is an emergency
here in New York City the best example
of this was the Legionnaires outbreak
that occurred in 2015 the mayor's office
of data analytics or Mota as we're known
we deployed to actually do a lot of the
number crunching and to integrate that
data in an emergency context and so you
can take that you can think about what
are some parallels
what are some faster analyses they need
to happen and last but not least
executive or legislative analytics this
is a part of working with in local
government specifically working with in
New York City we do a lot of the work
that is by law required for us to do to
actually analyze so we have a lot of
interesting work to do there we do work
on a lot of analyses that will inform
policy and so while I cannot get into
the details of all of those analyses
these are some broad questions that
we're currently working on we work on
helping people count we work as advisors
we work across agencies and then we work
to look at what are some policy impacts
or assumptions or references that we
should be thinking about and I think if
any of these questions strike you as
these are actually really interesting
questions you yourself have that is the
broader context in which we work within
the mayor's office of data analytics is
thinking about what are some questions
that we have about the world that we
live in about New York City specifically
it just so happens we got to do that for
a living which was pretty cool what do
we do I encourage you to go online
please please please read a little bit
more about all of our work bitly slash
Moda and read on we've done a ton of
work supporting tenant anti-harassment
efforts throughout the years the
universal pre-k roll out really our work
spans spans a lot of different fields so
I'm going to try to wrap up relatively
quickly here as I noted toward the
beginning we've we are really really
fortunate and lucky here we are here to
stay and I think that is something that
is always a measure of success is when
people outside of your team without
outside of your organization are able to
notice you and understand you so we were
actually written in in December into the
New York City Charter which is in effect
the constitution of New York City
local law 2 to 2 of 2018 and this is
something that were
incredibly proud about because it means
that we are we are moving forward and
one day I don't know what will be like
but we'll be around for 40 years like
some of our partner agencies and offices
I'm going to talk and give one more plug
on our open data program and portfolio
somebody sent me a note on LinkedIn
about our open data program and I saw a
few conference sessions about what is
available on NYC open data and how to
navigate it
we also in addition to everything else
that we work on also manage and oversee
the city's open data program we have
over 2,600 data sets that are available
online we are this country's largest
municipal data store of free data on
their some of our data sets I think last
year there were 10 million parking
violation data sets like you should
actually go on there and further explore
it is an incredible incredible resource
and earlier in September we actually
launched the next decade of open data in
thinking about what the future of this
is going to look like and not just be
data open data for compliances sake
because it is a law here in New York
City that you're required to publish
your data if it is public data but I
know a lot of folks are actually using
the information so if you look on the
left hand side here this was really
really neat the New York Times had done
a piece using the basis of the piece was
finding permits for block parties
throughout New York City and they
actually sent photographers out so you
can go look that up online and on the
right hand side this is a tool built by
I'm sure many of you have heard the name
Kris Wong formerly of the Department of
City Planning a day in the life of an
NYC taxi the point of great analysis is
how do you engage folks how do you
engage them in a way that they may not
actually be expecting
and I promised my deputy that I would
now talk about squirrels all the time I
was a little skeptical when she said
this great idea and we should partner
with the squirrel census and I said all
right and she won me over because this
has actually been an incredible
incredible story about the usage of NYC
open data first I had no idea that many
people were passionate about squirrels
maybe it's like a New York City thing
but it happened this is like taken off
the squirrel census is an incredibly
passionate group of individuals you'll
see this is actually a photo of adrian's
desk because I walked in one morning and
burst out laughing
she had a the data visualization from
the squirrel census done of Central Park
up up by her desk and so for me
continuing to think about how do you
engage using the data how do you engage
using analytics is so so critical to the
work that we do have a little fun along
the way
so now that I've talked to you a little
bit about everything that's done
throughout the country and a little bit
about what the mayor's office of data
analytics does I think the thing that I
want to close with is to remember that
it's not just our little team or your
little team but that there's a whole big
team out there of like-minded folks
what's really really been incredible is
that also over the last ten years as the
mayor's office of data analytics has
grown so have other data teams the fire
department the Buildings Department the
Parks Department across the city and so
I'm seeing like little data teams emerge
throughout all of these city agencies
and for me that is the point of all of
this work the point of all of this work
is not that people continue to come to
you the point is that there's other
people that they can go to throughout
the organization's and throughout the
the work that we do I struggled a lot as
a Bostonian to like put up in New York
City
story image put up friends gonna do Good
Will Hunting which is what I usually do
if I'm not in New York City but I put
this up here in part because our work is
about finding your tribe as I talked
about but it's also about good
storytelling and I think for anyone who
is traveled outside of the United States
people's understanding of American
culture is like New York City culture
and it's basically anything that happens
on friends they'll just ask you does
that really happen in America and I put
this up because I always want you to
remember to tell that story to figure
out how to tell the story to find the
other people who can tell the stories
with you that's what great analysis is
all about that's what a lot of
incredible incredible public servants a
few good ones and I think an emerging
number of them have done these are just
photos
this is potluck from two or three weeks
ago but these are just photos over time
of the incredible people that I've
worked with and that I can continue to
call upon and I think for anyone here
who hopefully I have not talked your ear
off but if you're ever interested in
working for government working as a
civil servant as a public servant at any
point in your career
send me some you know would love to chat
a little bit more I hope you guys have
an incredible incredible time here for
the rest of the PI data conference I
just want to say a huge thank you to the
organizers and the folks who invited me
today and I hope this was a good kickoff
for you all this morning thank you
[Applause]